[Musique]
je suis un musicien, j'écris mes chansons et je
joue de la guitare, du piano, du ukulélé et
un peu de leita, je ne sais pas, j'aime
et je
dis que
je dessine et je
fais les vidéos euh
je suis acteur actrice euh j'ai joué  dans le
théâtre de mon pays, de ma ville mais maintenant,
ce
théâtre ne
reste pas ici parce qu'il
est en panne. Le
bâtiment [de musique] aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que
je ne sais pas,
peut-être que c'est normal, c'est
très triste parce que
je lis les informations
toutes les cinq minutes et ces nouvelles  ce n'est pas
bien
notre ville est
vraiment brisée on dirait des détritus
ma famille dans ma ville
sous terre sur des bunkers
et ils m'envoient des photos et des vidéos quand
ils
entendent là-bas
et c'est très effrayant
[Musique]
je veux
travailler ou aller à l'école  et
dépenser de l'argent pour ma
famille parce que je ne peux pas les aider là-bas, je
peux les aider ici, nous voulons apprendre le
français, moi et mes amis parce que
je pense que c'est une très bonne chose, c'est très important
de vivre ici
à cette époque
et c'est important de
trouver  Un travail
et des études ici, ils prennent soin de moi et de
cette
ville place cet endroit vraiment
sympa pour nous, nous sommes très
merci
[musique]
aujourd'hui, je comprends que quand je remarque
comme que
je peux
jouer au piano
et que les
compositeurs
aident et que les compositeurs m'aident et  Je suis vraiment reconnaissant
pour que nous soutenions notre esprit et
pendant
ce temps,
c'est très important
[Musique]
Je suis heureux que je sois vivant, je suis heureux que
ma mère espéra en vie,
je suis heureux que mon chat soit la vie et  Ma
sœur jumelle est vivante,
mais j'ai toujours beaucoup d'amis
en Ukraine et mon cœur
en ce moment, je ne peux rien penser
à l'Ukraine parce que même si
chacun
que je connais
sera ici dans des pays pacifiques, il y a encore des
avocats
qui essaient de protéger
tout le monde  du mal et
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'aide, je fais de mon mieux
eux
et aussi j'aime ma ville et j'aime mon
pays
à cause de l'histoire que
vous